our final speaker for today before the
panel also doesn't need much of an
introduction at all Joseon Sione has
been a very eloquent voice for a reason
and what to do with nuclear weapons
pretty much since I was back in diapers
and not only since not only in his own
work but also through the as a leader of
the Ploughshares fun by supporting and
enabling so much other amazing work
that's been happening around the planet
so a warm welcome to Joe thank you very
much max thank you very much it's great
so max said ahead of an hour to do this
is there I'm going to try and talking
about 15 minutes thank you very much for
having me max it's been a pleasure
meeting you and thank you very much for
for coming and for taking the time I
know we all have lots of things that we
could be doing today I know we have lots
of things that worry us challenges we
face in our own lives our families
cities estate but of all the challenges
we face there are only two that
threatened destruction on a planetary
scale global warming and nuclear weapons
both of these are caused by machines
that we invented and both of them
threatened to destroy everything else
we've invented including human
civilization but both of these can be
stopped mitigated even reversed but they
both require new ways of thinking and
new leaders with the political courage
to take the actions needed to stop these
threats before they stop us
when President Obama was elected we
thought we had such a leader the speech
he gave in Prague seven years ago this
month was the most sweeping most
promising most complete most correct
policy speech on nuclear weapons that
I've ever heard a president give I was
proud to have served on his national
security team during the campaign and to
be part of the group that hammered
together the nuclear policy that he
brought into the White House and the
secretary Perry said in the first two
years he made enormous progress on that
agenda but when the New START treaty was
finally approved by the Senate at the
end of 2010 the nuclear policy team that
had been put together that it started
the nuclear security summits that had
hammered out a new nuclear posture
review that had negotiated the treaty
with the Russians that had gotten it
through the Senate over stiff resistance
was exhausted the president turned his
attention to other issues pressing
issues immigration the economy global
warming relations with China the pivot
to Asia many other issues that required
his attention and when he did so the
nuclear policy agenda started to falter
I just wrote a short article on this for
defense one this week you can look it up
it's called is that all there is Obama
is disappointing nuclear legacy a
reporter from the Los Angeles Times
called me up about it we talked as I was
driving to Max's house for lunch
yesterday and he bites he uses some of
my remarks in Los Angeles Times column
today
and it's my short analysis of why this
failed why despite his major
achievements Obama did not achieve the
policy transformation that we wanted
that we believe is absolutely necessary
and why the incrementalist in his
administration one out against the
transformation lists my shorthand for
this is the 3 R's and we have to
understand what went wrong if we're
going to have any hope of charting out a
path for the future and the first and
most important reason is the Russians
they stopped wanting to negotiate they
stopped wanting to negotiate I know this
for a fact they did not want to
negotiate any more reductions in our
nuclear weapons stockpiles we had a
partner in Medvedev he had the approval
of Putin but as the years dragged on
Putin decided this was not in his
interest this is not what he wanted to
do we couldn't get them to do the next
step you remember New START was just a
stopgap measure it was just to keep the
verification procedures and start going
it was to make a modest trim in the
forces and Medvedev and Putin and Obama
said it was there would then be a
another treaty that would make the deep
reductions both said they wanted we
never got there we never got there I
agree with secretary Perry we have to
keep trying we have to engage Russia we
cannot secure nuclear materials we
cannot make the reductions that we need
in global Arsenal's unless the US and
Russia are working together it's all
there is to it the second reason the
Republicans the Republicans politicized
national security in a way that we
rarely see it wasn't all Republicans
senator lugar was a partner in this that
the ranking member and then the head of
the Senate Foreign Relations Committee
was a partner in the
safford to move move the New START
treaty to but he was outflanked and
outgunned by the resistance wing of the
Republican Party led by jon kyl who then
dragged the treaty out exhausted the
process not just for the purpose of
blocking the President's agenda but for
blocking any more arms control treaties
particularly the Comprehensive Test Ban
Treaty that the Obama administration had
sort of queued up the plan was to
quickly get new start and then move on
to the Comprehensive Test Ban Treaty we
never got there Kyle's strategy worked
and in part they wanted to deny the
president the United States the
Democratic president of the United
States a major foreign policy victim in
2010 an election year they succeeded
they held it off until after the
elections of 2010 and finally and only
then did they approve it in a tough
battle on the last day of the Senate the
Republicans then felt their oats as the
president's attention wander the
Republican attention didn't they blocked
every step the president wanted to take
including many many of his appointees
this was trench warfare hand-to-hand
combat for those of you who haven't done
this in Washington it was brutal there
was nothing easy here there was no
simple step there was no oh yeah you
sent me a letter all thanks yeah I think
I'll just go do that now why did I think
of that no this was tough tough stuff
but the third reason is the reason I
think it ultimately failed despite the
Russians despite the Republicans it's
the resistance he encountered from his
own bureaucracy what I call the nuclear
industrial complex the nuclear
industrial complex including and I hate
to say this some of his own appointees
the people he put in charge of
implementing his vision many of them
never supported that vision many of them
mocked his vision privately so
everything slowed down everything
dragged down everything was a compromise
I gotta say I do not
no a defense official today who speaks
out in favor the president's vision they
go up to the Capitol Hill and they want
more money for more weapons at best they
give lip service to the President's
agenda but what they're really about is
moving the money moving the contracts
and this was the fatal flaw in the Obama
strategy as the policy faltered the
contracts raised on originally seven
years ago was all supposed to be part of
a package I will get arms reductions and
I will make sure and he says this in
Prague that we will keep a safe secure
and effective arsenal in order to do
that you got to spend money it's no way
around it and the truth was the George W
Bush administration had neglected the
nuclear complex those stories you hear
by Wayne water coming in about floppy
disks and our computers about
deterioration of the nuclear weapons
complex they're all true and there was a
backlog of money that had to be spent
just to fix this stuff plus a promise to
the Senators you you passed my new start
treaty and I'll support modernizing the
force this lovely word modernizing the
force who's against modernizing the
force wall modern
well that modest modernization has
turned into an avalanche of weapons that
threatens to bury Obama's achievements
we have a new bomber we have a new
cruise missile for the bomber we have a
new submarine we have new missiles for
the submarine when you have new warheads
for the missiles on the submarine we
have new fuses for the new warheads and
the new missiles on the submarine it
goes on and on we have a new MX missile
or not I'm a new ICBM and guess what we
don't just want to take the 450 ICBMs we
have and we place them know maybe we
need a mobile ICBM this is the latest
thing coming out a mobile ICBM this was
something we needed in the Cold War to
survive the so-called window of
vulnerability and we're talking about a
mobile ICBM again these people are drunk
on contracts they're proposing
everything and everything is being given
the green light everything there isn't
one weapon system inherited from George
W Bush that this president has stopped
he's added some and this is the tragedy
of this presidency the tragedy of this
promise it's not too late it is not too
late for the president for us for the
country for the world for those of you
who have spent years working on this
thank you for your efforts for those of
you who are new to this I congratulate
you and your timing because you're
coming in at a new policy moment a new
window is opening up for us similar to
the window we had in 2007 2008 2009 part
of it is the budget pressures I was
supposed to talk about the
trillion-dollar triad you know about the
trillion-dollar triad you know this all
these weapons cost a trillion dollars
over the next 30 years what you may not
realize that these were all planned when
everybody was
the defense budget was going to keep
going up well guess what it's not going
up its peak tits Plateau what they call
the inflection point and now it's going
down so you got this wedge of unfunded
programs moving through the future your
defense budgets you can't pay for these
something's got to give what's gotta
give we have to force the choice because
when the Joint Chiefs are forced to
choose they don't choose nuclear they
don't mind having these programs you
know missile defense program sure as
long as the budgets going up let's pay
for missile defense but when they have
to choose they choose the things the
Warriors need the planes the ship's the
tanks the things we actually need to
fight the conflicts were actually in so
this gives us a moment where we can over
the next two or three years cut cut
these back start to curtail this we have
heroes in the Congress that are helping
us do this just this week there was a
letter from Maria Cantwell she's the
ranking member on the Senate
Appropriations Committee in charge of
these budgets from Washington State if
Washington state was an independent
country be the third largest nuclear
power in the world through over a
thousand nuclear weapons based in
Washington State Maria Cantwell is
writing a letter Elizabeth's doubting me
I counted them I know I saw you this
have a thousand do they're in storage in
addition to the ones deployed
maria cantwell White's a letter
encouraging the president do a number of
things including take that one-third
reduction in nuclear weapons at the
Joint Chiefs and the president said we
could take and still accomplish all
military missions to make a renewed
effort to take this one third cut this
is the next step that we have to get our
leaders are taken she's joined by patty
Murray oh also from Washington and she's
joined by al franken and she's joined by
Jeff Merkley of Oregon and she's joined
by Elizabeth Warren and Ed Markey from
Massachusetts you have power that you
don't realize you got to let them know
thank you you got to let them know
there's political gain for them and
doing the right thing and doing the
thing they want to do ed Markey's been a
hero forever Elizabeth Warren is now
joining the cause work with them help
them encourage them support then it's
not so much they need your ideas which
they kinda sort of do they need your
political support you got to create the
political window the political opening
that allows them to do the right thing
we also have a political moment here in
addition to the budgetary pressures both
geopolitically and domestically
geopolitically I think Russia's I think
Putin might in the next couple of years
decide for his own interests that he
wants to reengage with the United States
again and that one of the ways to
reengage is on the strategic issue I
this is a state in decline his gambits
in Ukraine and Syria have not have
worked locally but not globally it has
it helped him break the isolation that
he's encountered we're the ones with the
global alliances we're the one with the
worldwide presence we're the one with
the biggest military in the world the
biggest economy the biggest cultural
influence in the world he hasn't gained
at all hasn't made a dent in any of that
at some point he's going to be ready to
turn we have to be ready to
to put out the hand of negotiation if
not friendship when they make that turn
when they make that turn that's ok
that's ok that's ok that's ok this
respect off instead of every
interrupting speakers is a warm up
interest it's ok i'm dealing with the
blue track the turtle five years
it's our big deal that's okay but we
also have this domestic moment if Donald
Trump is the nominee the Republican
Party and I believe he will be he is
going to split the Republican Party you
have to go back to Teddy Teddy Roosevelt
and the bull moose party to understand
what might be happening here this is not
normal something dramatic is happening
and if that happens it opens up all
kinds of political possibilities all
kinds of liberal conservative alliances
that could be possible in the next
administration and of course we're also
in a political election year eight years
ago all of us who wanted to change US
nuclear policy we're working with the
campaigns to feed in ideas to feed in
people to work on these things this is
what we have to be doing now working
with the campaign's would ever party you
with to feed in ideas to feed in those
and get ready for next year when we can
start to implement those ideas we have a
two-year window here domestically to
move this agenda forward for the new
president can come in and take bold new
steps there are other motion other
forces in motion but I've taken too long
so I'm going to stop with just this
final thought I've I've lived in
Washington for 35 years but I used to
live in Cambridge I was a community
organizer in Cambridge that's how I met
Jonathan we were doing tenet organizing
and low-income housing and before that I
was a student at Boston College and you
know what changed my life at Boston
College meetings like this teachings on
the Vietnam War small numbers of people
not the thousands we wanted talking
discussing analyzing teaching teaching
us telling us that we could stop this
war that we knew was wrong politically
morally strategically wrong
and some of us thought it was impossible
but you know what I've lived long enough
to understand that when people say
things are impossible what they mean is
that it's really hard I the impossible
happens all the time I've seen the
people of eastern europe rise up and
overthrow dictatorships that rule them
for generations I've seen the Soviet
Union collapse I've seen Irish and
Catholic in Northern Ireland that said
never never never unite shake hands and
rule together I've seen a man walk out
of a prison cell that held him for 28
years to be elected the president of a
free and majority ruled South Africa
I've seen the Red Sox win the World
Series three times
so don't tell me this is impossible it's
just hard thank you very much